hello everybody and welcome to another
1hour flipping challenge today we're
going to be doing
ammunition uh which I'm kind of
surprised I had didn't actually think of
this already cuz [__] knows I'm running
out of ideas please if you have an idea
leave a comment uh with any sort of
category or something I could flip for 1
hour this is episode number 23 and um
I've gone through all the obvious
categories so uh yeah we're going to do
1 hour flipping ammunition we're going
to start with 50 mil and uh we're going
to see how much we get in 1
hour all right guys we're just about
ready to start we are going to do 50 mil
and that is probably going to be too
much but there's a couple items that I
want to do that are actually ammunition
items like the dragon Throne axe uh that
might cost a bit more money so anyway
we're just going to have 50 mil we might
not need it all uh we have the RuneScape
Wiki page open here with all the
ammunitions listed and G tracker uh to
look up the prices and yeah let's do 1
hour let's go all right so I think we're
going to start with the dragon Throne
axe uh cuz that is by far the most
expensive piece of ammunition right now
uh so we bought for 41 150 I
think and sold it for 40K uh so we'll go
ahead and start buying those
um maybe just do a 100 another good one
that I've done a lot is the dragon darts
is definitely more expensive item here
but uh has a h 60
50 50 GP margin on it if we do a th000
that'll be 50k do more get more
obviously uh but we'll do
3136 and uh 3K would maybe it'll be
about 10 mil yeah we'll try 3K now the
diamond bolt e don't have a huge margin
but I already know this item trades a
bunch every day so we'll go ahead and
just put an offer in for 10k of those uh
because that's I don't know it's an easy
60k and it'll buy pretty quickly all
right we'll probably do the Rune Dart I
just checked uh the margin and it's not
too bad and there's a ton traded every
hour uh so we'll go ahead and buy some
Rune darts and uh
we'll we probably just do 10,000 to be
honest all the items from now on are
just beginning cheaper and uh we do have
some of everything coming through uh
granted a bit slowly but still we'll
probably get it eventually now the Ruby
bolt Enchanted also does um trade quite
a lot I just looked it up here it looks
like uh 38 to 4 30k in the last half an
hour uh so we'll definitely do 10k of
these uh we'll leave us with oh need to
remember to not buy quite 10K cuz I
think that is the limit and yeah we got
three more offer slots still um we might
do some of these Onyx bolt e uh the
margin isn't that good comparative to
the price uh but considering we still
have a good amount of money left and
we're probably just going to fill the
last offer slot with just Rune arrows or
something like that 26 and uh I mean
it's not it's pretty expensive but we'll
yeah we'll go ahead and do some try for
8810 all right we might do the r knife
uh had about a 30 GP margin on it which
is actually really good um probably
could get maybe 3,000 of them in an hour
I don't know uh we'll try for 687 oh
wait no it was only 13 GP but that's
still pretty good and do 4K of them
maybe sure and we still have one offer
slot Onyx bolts are coming through
Dragon Bolt darts are actually almost
all the way done and the rest of the
items are all coming through except for
these Ruby bolts which we might redo in
a second
here and last St I think I'm going to do
the dragon javelins it has a 19 GP
margin on it which is pretty good I'm
not sure how much I could expect to get
maybe uh
5,000 well we can't afford the full
anyway so we'll do 5,000 of these and
then that's pretty much our offer slot
all filled out all right so we've
successfully bought all the Onyx bolt
tips um we only bought a th000 so we're
selling them for not on here anymore so
we'll have to recheck it once uh but
since it was actually bought so quickly
I probably go ahead and flip more of
these oh I see what happened I [__] it
up that's why they sold so quickly damn
it all right I think we're going to pull
the dragon uh D whoa I just bought a
shitload of dragon Throne
axes oh my god um okay let's deal with
that first oh that's coming through too
okay I don't know what to do first um
probably the dragon okay well this is
done let's just do that let's try not to
[__] it up this time we bought it for
8810 and we're going to sell it for
8835 so we're selling 8835
confirm and uh that will give us 25k in
profit off the 1,000 so not too bad uh
we have a bunch of dragon javelins
coming in and the dragon Throne axes
will probably just popped into cell they
might take a while that was pretty lucky
I have to imagine um Dragon Throne axe
they are currently selling for 41 399 so
pretty good actually
41398 and there we go all right so we
bought all the Ruby bolt e uh pretty
much all in one go so that's nice um
someone must have just dumped them and
we had the price and eventually we got
them uh so we bought them
for what was it a what just happened how
do that even okay looks like the price
actually just crashed on us that's how
we ended up buying them all um let's pop
them in there for
403 and just wait cuz we're only 20
minutes in maybe the price will change
back again uh we are slowly selling off
these Dragon Thorn axes and the dragon
Thor axes are buying as well so we're
happy with that um and the rest of it
going pretty well to be honest all right
so all the throne axes sold pretty much
all at once which is pretty awesome that
is like a 90k profit there uh we still
buying some more they're coming in
slowly about 15 still and I think we're
going to pull out these Dragon javelins
they pretty much all bought and see what
we can actually sell them for so we're
selling them for 466 and we bought them
for 3982 that's a decent profit pretty
happy with that I think we're going to
pull these Dragon darts out to sell
they've been kind of stalling at that
point for quite a while and we sold them
for
6925 we bought them for
6786 um maybe we'll try buying more of
those actually if we can cuz it's a
really nice margin mind you we are
running out of offer slots kind of and I
would try another 3,000 of these that's
going to take up most of their money but
still pretty happy with that Dragon
Thorn axes we probably want to pop in
the cell somewhere here too um all the
diamond bolt ease have bought which is
nice so we can finally get more room
there Diamond bolt
ease think we bought them for
449 and sell them for
five or 454 sorry that's still a 5 GP
margin not too bad okay we sold off all
the dragon darts again that was
2,165 we have another 2592 to sell not
sure if we can get a actual good view of
the margin 6786 into 6925 that is uh you
guys know I'm bad at math you guys
figured out it's like a 100 to 200k
pretty good and we have another 2500 to
sell and we're popping those in there
for 3199 that is a great margin we're
definitely going to keep going with this
as long as we
can um that's one thing I recommend
especially if you're trying to take
advantage of doing quicker flips
definitely cut out what's not working
right away like these Onyx bolts I
should just I need to resell these just
get rid of them cuz they're not selling
quickly they're not having a good margin
it's not really going to be worth it at
all for me yeah so we're losing money on
the Onyx bolts now uh but that's okay
just get rid of them
8808 and but at the same time you can
see these I was going to lose money on
but I just popped them in there for a
higher offer and since they trade so
much they go up and down a lot uh it's a
pretty good chance of them actually just
buying selling for that price um which
which is nice all right since the dragon
darts are possibly our best item we're
going to go ahead and pop a another Buy
offer in we did 3,000 and then another
3,000 do another 3K just cuz I'm
not 100% sure of how many I have left to
buy and uh that's how much money we have
at the same time as well Okay so we've
sold all these Dragon Throne axes off
which is nice uh it's
another H it's hard to tell without the
full Mount being there um
15656 we made
and
17K which is insane especially for a new
item luckily I'm not actually getting
contested for this item right now I
don't think um but uh we'll go ahead and
recheck that Onyx bolts are through as
well we'll just take that and just take
the small loss not a huge deal Dragon
Throne axe let's just go recheck it cuz
that
our our best item easily
41 394 that's what I was selling it for
can't believe no one has undercut me at
all yet that's just insane and if it
sells for 40 oh oh someone did go for
200 and we have 19 mil in our inventory
we finally have some free offer slots we
could probably start popping some of
these items into sell all right looks
like the uh dragon darts got undercut
pretty badly so I think we're just going
to pull that Offroad and we actually did
sell off all the dragon javelins and
it's just over halfway now I'm not sure
if the margin is still going to be in
here no but I think we got like 100 to
200k on that like I said um we could do
some more of these Dragon javelins let's
go ahead and recheck the
[Music]
margin so it's still 829 into 802 so
we'll definitely go ahead and do some
more of these maybe just do a 2,000 or
something might be more realistic for 20
minutes or so and 2K of those and maybe
we'll do some more of these Onyx bolt
tips we have a lot of money in inventory
and uh not really much else to flip
they've dropped down to 8775 which is
not that awful margin
8776 and uh we'll do 2,000 because we
actually have 22 mil in inventory not
really doing anything all right all the
dragon javelins came through uh they
were slowly coming through for the last
minute and then some someone just bought
a couple thousand of them uh which is
pretty sweet 829 we're selling them for
1658 and we got them for 1606 yeah that
was actually right okay so I think we're
going to pop these Dragon Throne axes to
sell uh we probably should have done
that a little while ago cuz we have
almost 200 of them Dragon Throne
axes and uh
41393 I think it's the same margin
again
[Music]
and I think that's going to be pretty
much it we're going to try to sell off
the rest of the junk we have
um and I think we should be able to sell
it all maybe stop buying these on bolt
tips pretty soon and call it a day okay
so we sold off the Rune knives and uh
also we bought all the admin arrows so
we should probably get those into cell
quick because uh we don't have a lot of
time left uh we bought him for 65 and
we're going to sell him for
67 that's 20K if we actually sell anyway
and not a huge deal if we don't
realistically uh the Onyx bolts we're
actually going to sell for a decent
profit still
8833 on um
oops on 500 bolts we're going to
make um about 40K so not too bad all
right there we go the dragon javelins
are totally sold off that's nice all
right looks like the uh dragon darts
have reduced down quite a bit to 3161
but we still sold off the majority of
them for this decent margin uh so I'm
not too unhappy about that 3160 is what
we'll sell the rest of them for
3160 and uh yeah we're getting pretty
close to the end all right so we've sold
off some of the important ones here we
got the dragon Dart sold uh for 3160 and
um the Onyx bolt ease for 4.5 mil
that'll be about 40K in profit there
wait oh I guess the diamond bolts were
done as well all right next up to sell
is the Ruby bolt ease uh we sold them
for 396 so that was a I don't know 20
30k loss on those ones but still not
terrible next up is the Rune Dart just a
second later I have no clue what we made
on that probably pennies but it's still
nice to not have it uh cluttering up our
grand exchange all right so we got 5
minutes left and I've noticed it's been
probably a couple minutes since we
actually sold any of these uh so we're
just going to
recheck and we're selling them for 93
and 393 yeah know that's right okay well
we'll just leave it for a little while
all right I must have been undercut on
these Dragon Throne axes cuz we haven't
sold another one in quite a while uh so
we're just going to pop them down a
little bit cheaper just to hope we can
sell them in the last 2 minutes probably
should have done this a little while ago
but 31
299 see if we can sell off the rest of
these 26 in under 2 minutes and these
anim arrows are pretty much all sold so
that's pretty good all right we are down
to under minute left um we sold off the
item and arrows for 10K profit now I'm
not sure if these are actually going to
sell or not because they have
been whoa we just sold a bunch okay that
might be good we don't have to sell uh
one more until this is done so come on I
hope you saw this last one in the last
40 seconds but by far the MVP of uh this
hour has been the dragon Throne axe
after that
maybe the dragon Dart definitely a close
second um after
that maybe the Onyx I don't know after
that nothing really compared to the two
but still pretty happy with uh how this
went and I come on just sell that last
one six 5 4 3 2
one
a kind of sad about that but whatever
we'll pull this out and uh see how much
we actually managed to make so we're
actually up to 51 mil dump this last one
for a 1K loss not too bad all right guys
let's see how much money we made in 1
hour of flipping ammunition we have
made 1.1 mil which is very good I I've
tried this before and didn't get quite
nearly that much uh the dragon Throne
axes were definitely getting traded a
lot more at this prime time I'm doing it
at now as opposed to a couple days ago
when I tried this I didn't buy I only
probably bought like 100 Dragon throwing
axes then um so yeah it's definitely
possible to make some good money with
the ammunition of course like I said the
majority of that is coming from the new
item but Dragon darts work pretty well
darts knives uh bolts pretty good for
flipping all right guys hope you enjoyed
and I'll see you guys in the next
[Music]
video
pap